donc une rencontre qui va bouleverser
votre vie vous rencontrer gérard quand
vous avez 18 ans en 1962 oui bien loin
de paris vous êtes dans les ardennes
oui il va se faire passer pour le prince
charmant au début voilà c'est ça donc
gérard il n'a pas un prénom frère prince
charmant mais au départ on me croit
voilà alors voilà mais vous savez il
était tellement menteur ses parents
étaient dans l'import-export son cousin
lui a prêté sa voiture parce qu'elles
sont plus un c'est aussi quelqu'un ne
pas très bien et alors mes parents
indices on y est bien et est en réalité
ce n'était que des mensonges
alors que des mensonges et se trouvait
son charme commun vous êtes tombé sous
son charme
non j'ai je l'aimé pas il me faisait
peur ah ouais oui parce que jamais eu un
gros chagrin d'amour et et je m'étais
dit le celui qui viendra même si je
n'aime pas je l'épouserais pour ne plus
rester dans mon village donc et c'est
gérard qui est arrivé et c'est lui
malheureusement c'est lui qui a appris à
jouer
il est quoi dans la vie jura mais il
était alité et parachutistes
il s'était d'ailleurs c'était la fin de
la guerre d'algérie dont il était
parachutiste donc il était à givet et
donc j'ai rencontrés au bal comme ça il
y avait des bals toutes les semaines on
sait qu'il a je ne seriez pas de
confinement à l'époque n'y a pas de
causes qui normalise et des balles que
non alors vous êtes enceinte de six mois
oui et vous choisissez de le suivre à
paris alors et ailleurs mais il a dit à
mes parents va se marier faut que
j'apprenne entamé à mes parents et quand
on est arrivé à paris on aider ses
parents on n'est jamais allé chez ses
parents je suis allé dans une chambre
d'hôtel à pigalle et je sentais qu'il y
avait quelque chose et son cousin
arrivée puis disait memic mais qu'est ce
qu'elle fout question et il ya une
espagnole qui était venue avec son mari
et puis donc j'ai senti qu'il y avait un
danger pour beau bébé alors sur les yeux
jeu
lycées ma partie alors vous savez
j'étais tenu par les deux jambes les
deux bras et comme ce criait il m'a
donné un coup de poing dans le jeu ces
gens qui sont venus qu'est ce qui s'est
passé et puis après l'hôtel times et
puis elle m'a bien il ya une aiguille de
dans le montre dans le ventre et puis
que je me disais mais jury puis je
n'étais pas plus là j'étais déjà eu et
j'ai quand j'ai souffert pendant deux
jours deux jours et demi puis d'un seul
coup mon bébé devenu ces dix derniers
mois mon bébé devenait moi mon bébé
alors qu ils nous ont mis ce rebond je
le vois tous yeux il avait des blessures
tout son tour est joué ces petites
neiges et des puits de et les pays de
l'ue ont pris et puis j'entends d'un
seul coup mais renie pas cependant les
toilettes
alors vous savez pour notre 3e match
était plus rien j'étais complètement et
contenu complètement démoli jamais plus
de force
mes jambes seddik des bleus je pourrais
pu toucher le bras l'a jamais et et puis
après il m'a dit tu sais on n'a pas
d'argent faut que tu ailles travailler
tu as les marchés à la madeleine et moi
j'ai dit mais qu'est ce que je vais te
qu'est ce que je vais marcher à la
madeleine il m'a dit à des amis qui vont
aborder et et tuer j'ai montré d'hôtel
où tu va les emmener et jean marc et que
donc je suis je marchais moi je ne
connaissais rien moussa b g et moi
j'étais bière jusqu'à jusqu'à gerin
valeur et en plus ce qu'il m'a fait un
qui m'a fait mal comme tout jamais eu
déjà un mauvais souvenir de mon premier
rapport aux boules je vous dis pas qu'à
l'origine
mais ce qui qui m'a abordé puis on est
allés à la chanson et à la l'hôtel et
j'avais peur mon dieu je me disais je
vous ai même pas regarder alors il me
dit qu'il déshabille alors je me
déshabille josé m'a pas regardée son
sexe mais ce que si jamais j'étais trop
trop naïve 3 décalage
j'avais même pas 20 ans 19 ans et est
quelqu'un est donc plus une seule cuisse
ennemis mais il me lécher les pieds chez
les pieds et josé pas regardé une épine
liste masturber sur mac et et puis après
ils se masturbent hier me chalié puis il
a joui quoi et il est parti mdivani
prawna qu on va les prendre et quelque
chose qu à vis de la paix prix morny
j'ai pris un chocolat je fais un
deuxième client
on ne renie que j'avais 15 ans je savais
qu ils étaient 12 tu as quel âge tu as
quel âge je lui ai je disais mais à gg
19 ans au directeur
on aurait dit que j'avais 15 ans et
c'est vrai que linda là alors là on voit
donc il va vous pousser à vous
prostituées 1 voilà ce que oui c'est ce
que vous nous racontez il vous retenait
prisonnière dans cette vie dans la
prostitution
il vous battez beaucoup aussi oui j'ai
regardé mon usage le front l'arcade
sourcillière un coup de couteau
les normes à péter les dents il m'a tiré
dessus à 26 ans vous allez avoir un
enfant quand même avec gérard gg un
enfant parce que petite fille parce que
oui ça oui j'ai eu une petite fille que
j'adore et et vous savez j'ai eu la
chance puisque entre temps quand eux et
parce qu'il m'avait vendu
il m'a vendu un allemand de cabine ou
très riche d'ailleurs et et donc il
m'avait vendu 100 millions et il a été
porté plainte et il dit ils ont été
arrêtés lui son cousin et pendant et
donc il m'a dit tu vas chez mes parents
aussi la queue
j'ai connu et comme ils bouée puis mais
faire partie moi ma petite fille parce
que je retire barça mais sa mère je lui
aurais dit j'entends bébé puis veut me
faire encore du mal et donc j'ai eu une
fille j'ai eu une fille et oui non un
jour gérard va décéder d'un cancer des
os ou alors vous avez alors 50 ans oui
c'est oui c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour vous oui parce que vous
savez j'avais un ami prennent quand
j'étais tout se fait ouvrir son cousin
lui ont lieu il est mort il a pris deux
balles dans la tête
ah oui quand l'espagnol elle est tombée
et son mari guide al koni qui eux et et
mon mari je disais toujours pourvu
qu'ils mère pourvu qu'ils meurent parce
que j'avais dit à mon bébé tu sais
suivre je vais tous les faire beau et et
donc qu'il y avait un ami qui eux qui
faisait des voyages au mali où il m'a
dit tu sais de la maia des poupées est
les poupées je vais été ramenés il m'a
ramené trois poupées des poupées de la
chance vous paie d'un maladie poupées de
la mort et tous les jours je ne savais
pas et tous les jours j'ai piqué la mort
la mort mais m'a dit il faut que tu
dises le mot est aujourd'hui dix petits
mots qui me tient celui de dimanche mais
qui est encore qui m'embêtait qu'il ya
du tour j'ai connu toujours que la
violence à la gdi mais fermez là avec ta
miel prostate
ça n'a pas raté cancer de la prostate
incroyable oui cancer de la prostate est
le cancer de la prostate qui a dégénéré
dans l'iso linda juste oui c'est
absolument soignants en fait c'est
tellement fort votre livre moment de
votre vie vous avez été un esclave
sexuelle toute votre vie en fait j'étais
une esclave sexuelle alors justement
parce que comme sow et il a justement
après sa mort oui vous avez pourtant
continuer à vous prostituées c'est ce
que vous aimez vous savez j'avais un
studio à leurs jeunes jeunes avec des
habitués je ne remets bien que deux
la nuit le vendredi le samedi le
dimanche parce que vous savez nous nous
les grosses dix jours n'a pas de
retraite on n'a rien à leur nation donc
oui je faisais mes habitués et des amis
il m'appelait aux mureaux et je passe je
peux venir à quelle heure et puis voilà
c'est aujourd'hui vous avez votre
appartement surtout vous avez votre
fille with autre petit fils nous voulons
rien n'avait jamais parlé non jamais ma
fille regardez le hasard et ma fille
nagé ma fille ça dure doutey pascal g
j'ai fait des dépressions nerveuses des
crises spasmophilie et lui faisait
croire que j'étais folle alors vous
voyez et elle a dormi aide et leur
donner sa petite chaîne hôtelier taj
mahal fini beaucoup elle est rentrée à
la fnac et prennent prends mon lift elle
regarde derrière elle a tout de suite
compris l acheter mon libre elle a
découvert comme ça et elle a découvert
comme ça je suis je suis invité à
déjeuner chez elle le midi ils
habitaient la fête des menées et des
grands mères alors et avant de partir
elle me tend une enveloppe et elle me
dit que c'est pour toi maman
moi je croyais que c'était mon petit
fils qui m'avait mis un mot nos idées ma
fille qui me faisait net et elle m'a dit
maintenant maman je sais que tu m'aimes
parce que mafia du jour pensé que je
n'aimais pas je lui ai dit tu sais j'ai
passé mon temps ici de survivre merci
avec un musée dans un endroit et qu'on
m'a mis à l'abattage je faisais sans
clients par jour
linda l'ange de pigalle oui n'en a ni
figure et linda ces prostituées donc à
paris dès l'âge de 20 ans un monde
bientôt une prune femmes prostituées
comme le reste dont linda vous le
raconte merci m et linda d'avoir été
avec nous très très beau témoignage de
linda ce soir c'est un autre témoin du
jour
merci linéaire et on vous souhaite
maintenant beaucoup de bonnes mères si
je remercie mon cas vous êtes magnifique